i'd like to start off by noticing that
as each speaker gets up here the speaker
this speaker then goes ahead and answers
and his supporters get to go ahead and
applaud
i would like to start off by applauding
the people that
have the courage to stand up against
this hate
you're certainly welcome to applaud
anybody you like i take no
responsibility for who applauds for what
well you haven't given them space that
that was my point
um but i do have i do have questions
here
what i was saying is the structure here
has been
very specifically designed to go ahead
and to support a particular point of
view i'd uh could you give an example of
that because here's what i think happens
people come up and ask me a question and
then i give them an answer
and then somebody else comes up and asks
me a question and then i give them a
different answer is could you please
show me the nefarious
and unfair structure of that q and a
i'll i'll be happy to
because after their last comment you get
a chance to comment
and your supporters go ahead and applaud
when
when the speaker is then going ahead and
when the when the
person from the audience is talking you
immediately talk afterwards and there's
no
yes that's true because they're asking
me a question because i'm the speaker
and they're the ones asking the
questions
exactly right so i guess they can go
give a speech somewhere else
and then their their supporters can go
and applaud them but that's not what
we're engaged in here
so so you do agree then that there was i
agree that i'm giving a speech and
people are asking me questions i agree
with that yes
i didn't i didn't know that i had to
clarify that um so
so let me go ahead and uh frankly
there's so much
misinformation here i don't even know
where to start but i will try you talk
about
melting pots and assimilation i don't
know to what extent
you cook in the kitchen and you don't
cook i have no idea
well i'm of italian descent so i can
work my way around the kitchen a little
bit
if that's the case then you will know
that a melting pot is not something that
you take a pot you put the first
ingredient in
and you add other things and you expect
everything else to go ahead
and take on the flavor of that first
ingredient rather a melting pot
is a is a mixture of different
ingredients
and some of those ingredients you want
to blend in and other ingredients you
want them to maintain
their character and you don't want them
to blend in very much and you put them
in a particular order
and you you talk about what makes
america
there's plenty of things in this country
that are there are a huge problem and
there's plenty of things in this country
that are very good
one of the best things about this
country is is
that as each culture comes in
we're able to go ahead and look at that
culture and
take on the best things from that
culture this
america is not a english
only culture we have taken on from all
all different cultures and it's it's the
strength of this country
that we have gone ahead and taken on
it's the strength of this country
that you can't look at people and tell
which ones are americans and which ones
are not
that's what i said in my speech um
that's not that's literally what i said
in my speech what what you said is you
expect them to assimilate
right i expect assimilation and i said
it's a beautiful thing in this country
that you can't look at someone and tell
who's the american and who isn't
i said the exact same line that you just
said but but you seem to imply
that when people come in well you know
what they say happens when you assume
yeah is there a question or is this yes
yes what's the question okay so the
question is
do you realize that a hundred years ago
you you mentioned that previously people
have come in and then they
immediately assimilate a hundred years
ago there were
areas in new york city where you
couldn't function if you couldn't speak
yiddish if you couldn't speak german
if you couldn't speak a slavic language
130 years ago in kansas
the in a very large area in kansas
german was such a predominant language
that the native
americans assumed that the language in
this country was german
not english we've never been a true
tragedy we we've we've never had a
situation
where people come in and they
immediately start i never claimed that
people immediately assimilate
i never claimed that in my speech i
think you're making fine points they're
just not points that in any way
contradict what i've been saying this
afternoon
i'd like to ask just one more question
then i'll i'll leave
um in the past when uh the young
americans have had speakers here
you mentioned that each person gets one
question and you've been very
accommodating about letting many of us
have a conversation
but in in the past there's never been
that kind of
of a statement and i'm just wondering
why there would be a statement here it
sounds like you're afraid of having a
conversation
though i will admit that you have been
carrying on
on a conversation and um i just i just
want in closing i just want to say
that what's really important is that we
embrace other ideas and other cultures
not that we assume
or force people to go ahead and take on
what's already there
well i appreciate your comments i would
like to point out
that it seems you have criticized me for
saying things i didn't say
i agree with many of the points that
you've made and then you're criticizing
other speakers who have spoken for young
americans foundation
instead of me so i'm pleased that you
had a nice time at the lecture i agree
with many of your points
and i i love the open exchange of ideas
[Applause]
i heard you sir